제가 오늘은
빌딩 관리업체를 운영하는 그 d1도
대표님을 모셔서 그 프로그램이랑
어떻게 사용하는지 그런 것들을 좀
설명드리도록 하겠습니다
네
[박수]
안녕하세요
대표님이랑 인연은 거의 한 2년 정도
된 거 같아요네
처음에 이제 빌딩 관리
프로그램 개발하고 있을 때 저희가
어떻게 거의 첫 고객이었죠
관리하는
빌딩이라든지 이런 것들을 좀 이제
맡기면서 좀 뭐 이런저런 좀 피드백도
드렸었고 그리고 이제 최근에 좀 어느
정도 완성이 됐어요 저도 정말 좀
놀랄 정도로
굉장히 좀
퀄리티가 높은 그런 관리 프로그램이
나와서 여러분들한테 좀 설명 드리려고
좀이 영상을 찍게 됐습니다
우선 일단
시작하기 전에 좀 회사 소개 좀
간단하게 해주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
안녕하세요 저는
빌딩 케어라는 건물관의 소프트웨어를
만들고 있는
D 원더의 대표 이민호라고 합니다
저희는 최근에 건물들을
갖고 있는 분들이 카카오톡처럼 편하게
내 건물을 관리할 수 있는 그런
서비스가 있으면 좋겠다라는 그런
생각으로 개발을 한 시작을 했고요
그리고 1월부터 이제
본격적으로
베타 서비스를 런칭해서 지금 빠르게
고객들이 확장되고
성장하고 있는 중입니다 그래서 오늘
이렇게 좋은 기회로
초대해주셔서
빌딩 관리하고 있지만 기존에 다 이제
엑셀로 관련해서 주목 고구식이고
파일이 다 여기저기 흩어져 있고
그래서 저희가
인원들을
채용해 가지고 쓰면은 일거리들이 너무
많았어요 이런게 다 이제 여기저기
흩어져 있고 그리고 만약에이 직원이
일하다가 그만두면
인수인계를 할 수가 없어요 일단은
기본적으로 건물에 대한 정보들을
등록을 하면 건물에 대한 이런
보증금이나 임대료 관리비들이
들어가고요 그리고 건물에 대한
기본적인 주소를 기반으로 이제
건축물대장 정보들도 다 가져오게 되고
임차인에 대한 기본적인 정보들 거기에
대한 계약 기간 같은 것들이
들어옵니다 그래서
청구 같은 경우에도 뭐
호실에 대한 다양한 계약 같은 것들이
서류가 좀
온라인화 됐나라고 보시면 될 것
같고요 그래서 뭐 새로운 인원이
들어오거나 또 시간이 지났을 때도
서류를 뒤져보거나 파일을 찾을 필요
없이 여기 바로 들어와서 보실 수
있고 중도 퇴실이나 갱신 그리고
청구선을 보낼 때도 이렇게 실제로
임대료 관리비나 공과금 그리고 미남
연체 같은 것들이 있을 때 발행을
해서
종합청구서로
발행을 하면 등록된 임차인 카톡이나
문자로 이렇게 보낼 수 있도록 좀
만들고 있습니다 그리고 이제 호실에
대한 다양한 어떤 서류들이 굉장히
많잖아요
서류가
관리하는게 일인데 바로 이렇게 그
호실에 대한 클라우드로 넘어가서
이보실에 임차인의 서류들도 정리가 한
번에 쉽게
될 수 있고 더 다양한 대한 다양한
업체들의 정보들 그리고 뭐 검침이나
보험 화재 정기 이런 것들 챙기는
것도 또
굉장히 업무 스트레스인데 이런 걸
한번에 등록해 놓고 다양한 인원이
확인하고 처리할 수 있도록 만들고
있고요 그래서이 부분을 기반으로 일정
같은 관리를 할 수 있게끔 만들고
있습니다 다양한 인원이 건물에 대해서
내가 오늘 할 일들을
편하게 입력하고 또 그때 발생한 일에
대한 어떤 사진이나 이런 것들도
굉장히 많잖아요 굉장히 더 사진 찍고
파손이나 누수 있으면 또 업체 사진
계약서 이런 것들을 한번에 일정
등록하고 거기에 대한 서류 같은 것도
올려놓으면 시간이 지나서
검색을 할 수 있어요 그래서 여기에
누수라든지 나중에 뭐 건물에 대한
어떤 이름을 검색하면 몇 개월이
지났어도 그때 가서 바로 여기 안에서
아 이날 어떤 건물에 이런 일들이
있었지 이런 걸 알 수 있고
히스토리 관리가 돼서 내 자산 그리고
관리하시는 분들 입장에서도
관리를 대행해 주시는 입장에서도 투명
관리할 수 있는 그런 식으로 많이
열심히 만들고 있고
특히 이제
고객사들이 늘고 있는데
초반에 이제 저희 불쌍함이
굉장히 이런 일정 관리를 타이트하게
잘 써 주셔서 저희가 또 개발하는데
또 많은 인사이트를 좀 받았습니다
저는 딱 마음에 드는게 여기 건물관리
들어가 보시면 이게 약간 한눈에 볼
수 있어서 좋은 거 같아요
이런 것들을 다 보려면 다 일이잖아요
너무 좋은 거 같고 사실 만기나 뭐
연락처라든지 이런 거를 또 정리를 또
거의 안 하거든요 그래서 그 핸드폰에
막 이렇게 저장해 놓고
근데 이제
임차인이 많을수록 좀 이렇게 깔끔하게
정리해 놓으면 건물주분들이
쓰이시기에 너무 좋은 거 같습니다
메인 화면에 공실이
어디에 났는지 그리고 이런 식으로 한
번에 볼 수 있고 그리고 이제 뭐
계약이 한 달 이내 종료가 몇 번이고
그리고 어떤 건물의 계약이 한 달에
종료다 이것도 뭐 세 달 이내의
종류는 몇 개다 이런 식으로 바로
보실 수 있게끔 또 피드백을 다양한
고객들에게 받아서 만들고 있습니다
그래서 최대한
계약을 놓치지 않고 또 갱신이 그냥
자연스럽게 돼서 다시 임대료를 좀
인상 이슈가 있었는데 그런 걸
지나치지 않도록 내 자산을 좀
세계적으로 관리하는 세상이 오지
않을까 그런 생각을 하면서 만들고
있습니다 그래서 이게 왜 중요하냐면
그
종료될 때
서로 얘기가 없습니다
갱신한 걸로 보거든요
동일한 조건은
묵시적 갱신이 되는데
임차인의 경우는
묵시적 갱신이 됐을 때
언제든지 해지 통보를 할 수 있어요
어 나 나갈래 하면 이제 3개월 뒤
흐름이 발생되거든요
임대차보호법에 해당되는 이제 임차인인
경우 그래서 건물주한테 어떻게 보면
약간 안 좋은 거예요
임 다시 나간다 그러고 바로 이제
3개월 뒤에 효력이 발생되니까 그래서
계약 만기 전에
꼭 이렇게 알아서
계약서를 이게 또 새로 써야 되는데
그걸 놓치는 경우가 되게 많거든요
그래서
요런 이렇게 알림 서비스 이런 거는
좀 되게 괜찮은 거 같아요
최대한 저희가 말씀하신 것처럼 한눈에
보게 좀 하자라는 것들에 대해서 공을
굉장히 많이 드리고 있고요 그리고
데이터가 많잖아요 보셔야 되는게 많고
숫자도 사실 많이 바뀌고 이런 것들을
절대 새 페이지 이상 넘어가지 말자로
저희는 좀 많이 만들고 있습니다
그리고 이렇게
서류라던지 나중에
노트북에다 저장하시거나 하다가나 뭐
다
편화될 수 있어서 뭐 클라우드에 한
번에 저장하고
건물이랑 건물에 이제 내부 호실들이
자동으로 폴더들이 만들어지고 그래서
추가적으로 매번 폴더 생성해 놓고
하실 필요 없이 또 날짜랑 또 건물에
대한 폴더에 바로 서류들을 넣을 수
있고 여기에서 같은 것들을
검색하면 바로 찾아서 볼 수 있도록
만들었던 있어서 시간이 지났을 때
내가이 호실에서 사업자등록증이나
계약서를 어디에 나왔지
하면 여기에 검색하면 그 건물에
계약서를 좀 바로 볼 수 있고요
그리고 뭐 중요한 서류들도 있잖아요
그런 거는 이렇게
고정 형태로
눌러 놓으면
매일 상단에 고정이 돼서 이런 것들도
디테일하게 좀 만들고 있고 최근에
이제 베타 버전으로 건물에 대해서
자산을 리포트를 좀 자동으로 생성하는
기능을 좀 메인으로 추가를 하고
있어요 그래서 내가 갖고 있는 건물의
리포트들이 있고 여기에 대한 이제 뭐
임대차 현황 같은 것들을 자동으로
긁어오고 그래서 뭐 여기에 대해서
내가 필요 없는 것들을 세팅을 해서
이번
달 또 주간에
현재 내 자산은 어떤 방식인지 이런
것들을
커스터마이징 할 수 있도록 해놨고요
그리고 뭐 나중에는
지출에 대한 내역 같은 것들도 일일이
다 정리하시잖아요 비용계산도 자동으로
될 수 있게끔 만들어 놔서
내 자산에 대해서
리포트 형태로 점점 자동화가 돼서
아네 이게 쌓이면
연간의 어떤
계획
차후에는 이제 내 건물을 가지고
어떤 것들을 조금 올리면 내
자산가치가 올라가는지 또 어떤
부분에서
지출이 많이 발생하는지를 체크하고 그
부분에 대한 어떤 솔루션을 받을 수
있게끔
고도화를 하고 있습니다
저도이 업을 하면서 좀 이런게
생겼으면 좋겠다라고 생각을 굉장히
많이 했는데 좀 이렇게 만드셔 가지고
좀 건물주분들이 좀 이렇게 저
개인적으로 좀 쓰셨으면 좋겠어요
그리고 좀 미리 말씀드리지만 이거는
사실 광고가 아니야
뭐 전혀 또 비용을 받거나 뭐 그런
건 아니니까 오해는 안 하셔도 되고
저희 구독자분들 중에서 일단 건물을
또 가지고 계신 분이 있을 거고 중계
업체 있으신 분들도 있을 거예요 근데
이제 중개업체 중에서도 그 빌딩
관리를 맡고 계신 분들도 있을 건데
근데 그분들도 사용하기에 좀 되게
좋은 프로그램 같아요네 맞습니다
그래서 저희가 중개법인이나 공개를
하시면서 관리를 하시는
기업 분들한테는 무료로 컨설팅
해드리고
업무를 어떻게 하고 계시는지 그리고
이제 도의 문의하시면
어떤 식으로 도입하면 좋은지에 대한
상담을 해드려서 그런 부분을 뭐
이번에 신청해주시면 제가 그걸
도와드리는게 하나가 있고 그리고 이제
건물주 분들이 쓸 수 있는 가벼운
버전을 저희가 준비하고 있어요 그래서
유튜브 뭐
댓글이나 이런 거에다가 링크를 저희가
걸어드리면
신청해 주시면 미리
써보실 수 있게
컨설팅 해드리고 그런 부분을 제공을
해 드리니까
신청 많이 해주시면 저희가
선별해가지고
서비스를 좀 제공해 드리는
목표로 하고 있습니다 보안 같은
경우에는 아마존 웹서비스라는 최고든급
보안을 사용하고 있고요
인원이 조금 많은
기업 같은 경우에는 내부의 권한에
등급들을 저희가 좀 나눠 놨어요 누가
정보를 만약에 악의적으로 다운을
받았다 이력 같은 것들이 다 남아서
저희가 그런 부분을 좀 세세하게
신경을 쓰고 있습니다
그래서 비용 같은 경우에는
빌사남을 통해서
신청을 해주시면 저희가 이제 코드
같은 것들 하나를 이제 열어 드릴
거예요 그래서 베트남 유튜브 보고
신청을 했다 하면 저희가 뭐
프로모션을 해서 좀 드리려고 하고
있고 지금은 관리하고 있는
혹시를
기반으로 저희가이 사용료를 책정을
하는 방식으로 하고 있고 이게 이제
미국에서 이런 소프트웨어가 발달했는데
그 미국의 모델을 저희가 좀
합리적으로 채용을 해왔습니다 제가
이번에 그 프로모션 그 기간을 한
어느정도
프로모션 같은 경우에는 이제
업체 입장에서 그러니까 특히
B2B 업체 같은 경우에는 저희가 한
3개월 정도
프로모션을
드리려고 하고 있고 그리고 이제 개인
건물주분들이 오시면 건물주분 같은
경우에는 저희가 한 달은 무조건
무료로 사용하실 수 있게끔 하려고
하고 있고 그리고 호실 하나당 지금은
프로모션가로 하면 5천원 정도
생각하고 있습니다 생각보다
그렇게 비싸진 않네요네 맞습니다 아마
시간이 지나서 뭐 모바일 버전이나
제품이 고도화가 될 때
부분적으로 가격에 변동은 있겠지만
지금
기간에는 지금 가격으로
진행을 하려고 하고 있어서 지금
신청해 주시면 저희가 좀 굉장히 좋은
가격에
도입해서 쓸 수 있지 않을까 생각하고
있습니다 건물 관리 프로그램에 대해서
좀 설명을 드렸는데 아마 되게
생소하실 거예요 대부분 다 직접
관리하실 것 같습니다
근데 좀 이제 앞으로 이런 관리
프로그램이라든지 이런게 좀 되게
고도화될 거라고 저는 생각을 하고
그래서 지금 만약 건물을 가지고
계시는
분이 한번 좀 써보셨으면 좋겠어요
앞으로 이렇게 변하실 거예요 그리고
되게 좀 편하게 쓰실 것 같아요이
프로그램을 테스트 삼아 일단 한번 좀
써보시고
빌딩 관리하는데 있어서 좀 도움이
되셨으면 좋겠습니다 그래서 오늘 모신
그 디원더 대표님
영상은 여기까지 하고요 다음 시간에
또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다